(flute music)
- Hey, c'mon in.
(1980's exercise music)
- [Brody] Yes!, Push & Believe.
You got it.
- Hey.
- Hey, Baron!
- How ya doin' man?
- Great to see ya buddy!
- Good to see you.
- Making a protein
shake, I'm outta ice
I gotta run down
to the ice machine.
- Oh, okay, sure let's go.
I think you got enough,
I think you got enough.
There's a, I think there's a...
I think
- Got our ice.
Let's go make some protein.
We've got the ice.
We got the protein powder.
We got all the ingredients
because I'm a healthy guy
and you gotta get
the ingredients.
So you a banana guy?
Are you a strawberry guy?
You a carrot guy?
- Can I eat this one?
- Yeah if you're willing to.
Healthy. You're
vision's getting better.
I'm becoming attractive.
Alright so we've
got some carrots,
what do you think we
should put in there next?
- One of these bananas?
- You peel one,
I'll peel the other.
- Okay.
- And I go like that.
- You know I actually
peel 'em from the side.
- You peel from that?
- Yeah.
- Why is that?
- 'Cause this is a handle.
If you peel it from
this side, guess what?
You get more of the banana
and you have a way to hold it.
- But how do you,
wait but how do you--
- You can't do it--
- Now it's like corn.
- That's true.
- Just throw the
peel on the ground.
- Okay.
- Just throw it on the ground.
See ya later.
Somebody's gonna slip on
it and it's gonna be funny.
That's why Comedy
Central wants to do that.
I'm gonna drop in.
- Okay
- Drop in.
- Some soy milk.
- Soy milk.
Let's just do a little,
tell me when, say when.
- And done.
- [Brody] And
done. Strawberries.
- All of 'em, gotta
put all of 'em.
- Dump 'em all in.
Three, two, one, they're in.
Somebody toss me an orange.
- Orange!
- Bingo! Orange, there ya go.
I'm not sure how to peel that.
- Neither am I.
- You're taking a risk.
I'm gonna do one and a half
scoops of protein powder.
There's the protein, that
is muscle development.
- Get on the ground.
- Get down on the
ground orange peel.
- So this is not an
orange, like a nectarine?
- I put the wrong cap,
you know what's funny?
I just took the blender cap
and put it on the protein.
It's crazy!
- It's very crazy.
- It's crazy. Okay.
- Alright.
- Oh, you know what we forgot?
- What?
- Ice. I mean, why did we go,
- That's true.
- Why did we go, I mean
we did a whole ice thing.
I'm gonna let you do the ice.
- You tell me when on the ice.
- Okay.
That's great.
Okay, so Baron tell me a
little about, are you excited?
You're doing your special here?
- I'm so excited man--
(blender noise
drowns out speech)
when you have like, depression.
- Exactly.
- I mean I have material--
(blender noise
drowns out speech)
so that way I can say things
like, "mothersmurfer."
- That's what I'm talkin' about.
- Yeah.
- Okay I can't quite get the...
- Is there a thing?
Okay, yeah, you just gotta
pour the whole thing.
- Yeah, we're gonna
- Okay, here we go, boom! Ha ha!
- Look at the thickness.
- That looks great.
- Okay if you can help me out.
Team work.
- Team work.
- [Baron] Cooperation.
Yes!
- Yes! You got it!
- Boston. Friendship. Tweeting.
- Boom.
- All those things.
You know, let's do a toast.
- Do a toast.
- To a half-hour special.
- Half-Hour of comedy.
- To Boston.
- Friendship.
- Energy.
- Las Vegas.
- Friendship.
- Enjoy.
- Oh I will.
That's pretty good.
- It really is good.
(Baron laughs)
- It's pretty good.
- This is good!
Click.
Like.
Subscribe.
Click and like it on Facebook.
(overlapping dialogue)
Subscribe.
Believe.
And like it on Facebook.
Subscribe.
Believe.
Like it on Facebook.
Subscribe.
Believe.
Like.
Believe and like it on Facebook.
Subscribe.
Push.
Video I'm glad you liked it.
Believe.
Like it on Facebook.
Subscribe.
Push.
Believe.
Subscribe.
Like.
Believe.
Subscribe.
Woooo!